der nächste aufreger der auch hier
tatsächlich bei uns passiert ist bei
bild ist helge braun und eine
verrechnung sag ich jetzt mal gleis war
keine ganz so kleine verrechnung helge
braun hat vor acht wo also im juli hat
er gesagt wenn wir keine enorm hohe
impfquote oder verhaltensänderung
dagegen setzen würden hätten wir nur
neun wochen eine instanz von 850 das ist
nicht eingetreten deswegen auch helge
braun der zeitschrift acht wochen später
keine enorm hohe impfquoten keine
verhaltensänderung incidents der noch
bei 70 da sieht man ganz klar er hat
sich einfach schlicht verrechnet und da
muss man ganz klar sagen anstatt dass
helge braun sich jetzt hinstellt und
sagt entschuldigen sie mir tut das
horrorszenario leid hat er noch gesagt
ja das liegt an den maßnahmen und das
ist ja die ganze zeit so also die
politiker machen falsche prognosen die
wissenschaft übrigens auch und hier
möchte ich ganz klar sagen wissenschaft
darf sich irren das ist menschlich auch
politiker können sich irren das ist
menschlich aber dann müssen sie doch
sagen es tut mir leid dass ich dieses
horrorszenario den menschen mit gegeben
habe und da würde ich ganz klar sagen
diese diese horrorszenarien wir brauchen
endlich eine debattenkultur über falsche
prognosen die den menschen angst macht
die debatte findet ja auch statt helge
braun hatte die gelegenheit heute in der
bild zeitung auch einen kommentar zu
schreiben und seine sicht auf die dinge
noch mal darzustellen und da hat er ja
darauf hingewiesen dass es halt immer
schwierig ist wenn man sozusagen
prognosen abgeben maßnahmen einleitet
und wenn dann die ergebnisse
entsprechend nichteintreten also
eigentlich ein positives ergebnis
erzielt wird dass man aber nicht sieht
weil eben nichts passiert ist dann ist
das halt immer schwieriger zu begreifen
aber der ist es ja eine ganz einfache
ausrede es ist ja immer zu sagen nein
das wäre ja eingetreten aber helge braun
ich glaube wenn helge braun heute mal
ganz ehrlich zu sich wäre würde er sagen
die institute zwar vielleicht ein
bisschen hoch gegriffen die ich da eine
wand schwarz gemalt habe ich glaube ja
schon länger dass wir vor allem unter
einer politik pandemie leiden weil man
muss ganz klar sagen natürlich müssten
maßnahmen getroffen werden aber die
horrorszenarien die immer wieder an die
wand gemalt wird da kann man auch
argumentieren es gibt andere länder dem
schon länger keine maßnahmen denn es ist
nicht gestiegen und thomas eine sache
noch der incidents wert der wurde jetzt
auch zu recht in frage gestellt also
selbst zurecht auch ein umdenken in der
politik angekommen dass man eher auf die
hospitalisierung raten schaut anstatt
auf diesen horror incidents wert und ich
finde schon dass helge braun in dem fall
wirklich ein falsch rechner war und ich
erwarte einfach mal das mal dass ich mal
jemand hinstellt und sagt ich habe mich
geirrt ich bin wahrlich keine freundin
von karl lauterbach ist bin ich nicht
aber karl lauterbach hat damals bei bild
live auf falsche prognosen von sich
zugegeben und das war wichtig und
richtig weil die menschen müssen merken
die wissenschaft kann sich irren die
politik auch und es darf nicht länger
immer dann gesagt werden ja das ist
nicht eingetreten weil das ist nicht
eingetreten wegen ich fände es toll wenn
und deswegen war für mich heute helge
braun äußerungen war für mich nicht von
wegen es tut mir leid das horror
szenario also deswegen bleibt weiterhin
bei der fei rechner
[Musik]